so we learned already how we can pass
the poi at our toes in front of us
and on a rainbow in front of us and
that's great the poi can also pass
behind you so we're gonna start passing
the poi behind at our shoulders so for
me I've got my dome you've got your
you're facing me put the poi behind you
so your hands are kind of scratching
your shoulder blades and again just see
if you can feel them swinging side to
side right and my hands aren't moving
much it's more I let my body wobble
right you don't do this with your arms
your hands are just hovering at your
shoulders and you sway a little bit to
get the ploy going once I get a bit of
omentum you just swing them around like
you're chopping firewood at the shoulder
if you go swing swing and swing all the
way around chop you can do it a bunch of
times and either other side so now that
you think the fireworks at your left
foot you go
swing swing around right now to go back
I'm going to flip them up to go to my
button turn back to the dome and I can
swing swing swing and chop down the
cranes now again I turned all the way
that's important if you don't turn all
the way it won't work then I can stop I
can swing the poi back and put them back
behind me you can pretend they're swords
so you go swing swing swing and chop
then stop then put the swords back in
the scabbards
swing swing swing around and you can
kill the Goblin if you're a goblin
killer then stop put the swords back in
the scabbards and you end up with a
pattern like this you kill a goblin on
your left a circle you're going to swing
kill a goblin and your left stop
put the scabbards back kill the Goblin
and your right
put them back past your butt kill the
goblin past your bus kill the goblin
past your butt kill the Goblin past your
bus kill a goblin now what happened
sometimes is this this will work fine
when you put them back it'll go like
this or something right the POI one of
them tries to pass you in front so let's
look at that let's face this way you're
spinning away from for me I'm coming
away the museum's pinning backwards when
I turn it's like I want the play to hit
me and it's like I'm gonna let both boy
hit my left butt cheek right but just
before it hits me I turn so it misses
that butt cheek right if I'm going this
way
think when I turn with which butt cheeks
going away it's gonna be my right butt
cheek
so the poi it's like I want them to hit
the right butt cheek
although the hands are is coming to the
shoulders and at the last minute I turn
so it misses me right I aim for my left
butt cheek and I turn I aim for my right
butt cheek and it turns off secretly so
I can talk about my butt cheeks in a
video yeah over the shoulders and turn
over the shoulders and turn now another
thing that goes wrong is people will do
this and they'll go like this now that's
a rainbow turn that's a turn in front
that's it one circle kaboom which is
great but it's not what we're learning
what we're learning you can count it
goes one
two three three circles going backwards
one circle two circle three it's
counting out loud you need to feel it go
like it's light you're a put in your
back pockets over into the back pockets
and forwards backwards into the back
pockets and forwards backwards into the
back pockets and forwards now once it's
beginning to work you can keep doing it
the same way just walk your golf ball
down behind your shoulders forwards
whack a golf ball you're backwards
behind your shoulders and you're
forwards again whack a golf ball behind
the shoulders whack a golf ball behind
the shoulders eventually golf ball
behind the shoulders golf ball behind
the shoulders golf ball shoulders golf
ball shoulders golf ball shoulders can
also go backwards in this set shoulders
golf ball shoulders golf ball shoulders
golf ball shoulders golf ball doesn't
have to look like that this week will
keep coming back to this just start up
as long as you've got through it a
little bit so as long as you can go past
your button forwards in each direction
also backwards starting this way over
the shoulders and forwards that's enough
for this week if that's working great
see if you can roll it over the
shoulders whack a golf ball over the
shoulders golf ball shoulders golf ball
but it doesn't have to be perfect as
long as you've got it started and if
you're not sure post a video and I'll
tell you whether you've got it or not
but when you post that video remember to
show me leading up to it and then I'll
know what's going on so I really hope
that works I think for most of you what
it'll work and if it doesn't I will it
will work I will help you
you